طائرات الحوثيين وصواريخهم تحلق فوق
الاسطول الامريكي الجيش العبري يعلن توسيع
زحفه البري وادخال مزيد من القوات
القتاليه رئيس الوزراء الكندي يدعو الى
تكثيف الضغط الدولي للوقف الفوري لاطلاق
النار في القطاع وحديث فرنسي عن معضله
الانفاق التي تواجهها تلبيب وتضيق الخناق
على جيشها اعتراف عبري باغتيال قائد
ايراني وهولندا تحضر جيشها لمواجهه الدب
الروسي هجوم صاروخي روسي هو الاكثر كثافه
والسلاح الجوي الاوكراني يعلن عجزه امام
صاروخ روسي بريطانيا تمنع الاوكرانيين من
استخدام دباباتها في الخطوط الاماميه
للجبهه فما
السبب امر غير
متوقع حرب دخلها الكيان لينهي في فتره
وجزه لكنه وجد من لم يكن في الحسبان هنا
تقرير في صحيفه لوموند الفرنسيه تناول ما
سماه معضله الانفاق التي تواجهها تلابيب
وتضيق الخناق على جيشها قائلا ان دخول
الانفاق يتطلب انخراط القوات العبريه في
صراع طويل الامد اكثر خطوره من حرب المدن
والفشل في استكشافها يترك للفصائل امكانيه
لتطوير قوتها من جديد وتنفيذ هجمات جديده
خلص التقرير الى ان الفصائل اتقنت بناء
الفخ خلال 20 عاما واليكم المصدر ما كشفت
وكاله الامم المتحده لاغاثه وتشغيل
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين الاونور ان جنو
عبريين اطلقوا النار على قافله مساعدات
اثناء عودتها من شمالي القطاع على طريق
حدده الجيش ليؤكد المكتب الاعلامي الحكومي
في القطاع ان الجيش العبري دمر اكثر من
200 موقع تراثي واثري في القطاع هناك تلقى
ملك الاردن عبد الله الثاني اتصالا هاتفيا
من رئيس الوزراء الكندي جاستن ترودو دعى
خلاله الى تكثيف الضغط الدولي للوقف
الفوري لاطلاق النار في القطاع وميدانيا
اعلن الجيش العبري توسيع عمليه البريه
وادخال مزيد من القوات القتاليه لتفكيك
قدرات الفصائل وكشف الجيش العبري ان قوات
اللواء الخامس تعمل لاول مره في منطقه
خربه خزاعه الواقعه جنوبي القطاع واوضح
الجيش ان هذه المنطقه هي التي اطلق منها
عناصر الفصائل الهجوم على مستوطنه نير عوز
في السابع من اكتوبر وها نحن نتصفح
المصدر
[موسيقى]
على الحدود اللبنانيه قال الجيش العبري
انه شن هجوما واسعا على اهداف تابعه
للمقاومه اللبنانيه استهدف خلاله خليه
اطلقت صواريخ مضاده للدروع صوب الاراضي
العبريه هذا واعلنت فصائل عراقيه استهداف
موقع عبري قرب محافظه اربيل فيما تواصلت
الضربات على مواقع الوجود العسكري عكري
الامريكي في المحافظه ذاتها ياتي ذلك في
وقت اكدت فيه الحكومه العراقيه عزمها
انهاء وجود القوت الامريكيه داخل العراق
بعيدا عن الحرب الجاريه قال رئيس الوزراء
العبري السابق نيفالي بنات لصحيفه و ستريت
جورنال ان تلبيب هجمت ايران عام
2022 حيث نفذت عمليه اغتيال ناجحه لمسؤول
ايراني كبير في اعتراف غير مالوف في
السياسه العبريه وفي البحر الاحمر كانت
القياده الوسطى الامريكيه اعلنت اسقاط
طائره مسيره وصاروخ بالستيا مضادا للسفن
اطلق الحوثيون واشارت القياده الى عدم
التسجيل اصابات او اضرار في 18 باخره كانت
في المنطقه وقت الهجوم ولنات بالمصدر
اعلنت القياده الوسطى الامريكيه اسقاط
طائره مسيره وصاروخ بالستي مضاد للسفن
اطلقه ما الحوثيون جنوب البحر الاحمر
الليله الماضيه واشار بيان القياده الوسطى
الى عدم تسجيل اصابات او اضرار في ث
باخره كانت في المنطقه وقت
الهجوم استعداد
الحلفاء مع اعتراف حلفاء اوكرانيا باقتراب
خساره كياف للحرب يتحضر الحلفاء لاطاله
امد المعارك لاكبر قدر ممكن هنا اعرب
متحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه الالمانيه عن
ثقه برلين بان الاتحاد الاوروبي سيكون
قادرا على المضي قدوما في تقديم الدعم
اللازم لاوكرانيا حتى في ظل استمرار
الاعتراضات من هنج
مشيرا الى ان مساله تخصيص 50 مليار يورو
لاوكرانيا نوقشت في قمه الاتحاد الاوروبي
هذا الشهر ولكن تعذر الاتفاق عليها بسبب
موقف هنغاريا مؤكدا ان برلين ستواصل حمله
نشيطه من اجل تبني حزبه المساعده هذه في
بدايه العام المقبل من جانب اخر نقلت
صحيفه دي تيليغراف الهولنديه عن القائد
العام للجيش الهولندي مارتن فينين قوله ان
هولندا يجب ان تستعد لحرب محتمله مع روسيا
ولذلك يحتاج الجيش الى المزيد من جنود
الاحتياط والمتطوعين حتى يكون قادرا على
استمرار اداء مهامه اما في بريطانيا فاعلن
وزير الدفاع جراند شابس على منصه اكس ان
لندن سترسل المئات من صواريخ الدفاع الجوي
الى اوكرانيا لازلنا في بريطانيا حيث منعت
لندن مؤخرا الاوكرانيين من استخدام
دباباتها تشالنجر اثنان في الخطوط
الاماميه للجبهه كما سحبت الولايات
المتحده بعض اسلحتها ايضا واعادتها الى
الخطوط الخلفيه ويكمن سبب هذا القرار
البريطاني في خوف السلطات البريطانيه من
فقدان ما تبقى من دباباتها في اوكرانيا في
فتره وجيزه من الزمن بعد زجها الفشل في
القتال ويؤثر هذا الامر سالبا حسب
البريطانيين على سمعه المدرعات البريطانيه
بالعوده الى المانيا قال اللواء كريستيان
فرود وينغ الذي يراس اداره الشؤون
الاوكرانيه في وزاره الدفاع الالمانيه في
مقابله مع صحيفه سي دويتش تسايتونج ان
قرابه نصف دبابات ليوبارد اثن ال 18 التي
حصلت عليها اوكرانيا لم تعد صالحه للعمل
واضاف اللواء فروي دينغ انه تم تدريب اكثر
من 100 الا عسكري اوكراني في المانيا على
الارض الاوكرانيه استهدف الضربات الروسيه
استمرت عده ساعات مواقع في عدد من المدن
الكبيره منها العاصمه كياف وفوف وخاركوف
واوديسا ود نمبر وبيترو فاسك وزبور ومناطق
اخرى ليصف المتحدث باسم القوه الجويه
الاوكرانيه يوري اغنات الهجوم الصاروخي
الذي شنته القوات الروسيه على مختلف مناطق
اوكرانيا بانه كان الاكثر كثافه منذ فتره
طويله يوري اغنات عاد وقال ان قوه بلاده
لم تتمكن من اسقاط اي من 300 صاروخ من
طراز خا 22 التي اطلقها الجيش الروسي منذ
بدء عمليته العسكريه الخاصه هذا واعلن
الجيش الاوكراني اسقاط 114 هدفا جويا من
اصل
158 اطلقتها روسيا تجاه الاراضي
الاوكرانيه خلال 24 ساعه وها هو المصدر
يتحدث سلاح الجو الاوكراني قال بان الجيش
الروسي استخدم جميع ما يملك من الصواريخ
باستهدافه الاراضي الاوكرانيه باستثناء
صواريخ كاليبر وصل عدد هذه الاهداف
المعاديه وفقا للجانب الاوكراني
18 هدفا معاديا من جانبها اعلنت الدفاع
الروسيه ان قواتها نف 50 ضربه جماعيه
وضربه مكثفه واحده باسلحه عاليه الدقه
وطائرات مسيره لمواقع الجيش والبنيه
التحتيه العسكريه الاوكرانيه خلال اخر
اسبوع واظهرت بيانات الدفاع الروسيه ان
خسائر الجيش الاوكراني خلال اسبوع بلغت
نحو
4685 جنديا اضافه الى عشرات القطع من
المعدات
العسكريه